taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two foods gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
here we go taste buds here we go
sally little league-ish what's up buddy
how you doing good and we're back
everybody
we're back we're getting a hot one today
also it's like 103 degrees out
yes yes we're getting a hot one though
i'm getting text messages about the heat
saying
like like from con ed saying like in
case your power goes out because of this
heat
oh it's like that yeah it's crazy oh
well the grid can't handle
that's what they're are you getting
would you say text messages
mm-hmm con edison has your t has your
did they text you
well i get an insight man
you have an inside manic on it i don't
mean to brag but i know it
con ed he's a good guy no yeah you know
they got your number for when you sign
up and they send you like a mass text
and they're just like be careful today
just not be careful just saying like hey
just be aware like the heat this is a
considered a heat wave
and if the heat does go out the power
does go out because of it
we're standing by i know they say like
check on these days like this they say
check on your old people right
uh yeah they do right they just say what
do old people do out in like
zona arizona i don't know if a lot of
old people live in arizona i've never
called arizona zona in my life yeah
no i just i don't know if you know
that's a thing i said it and as it came
out of my mouth i did not like it
and then i corrected it to arizona the
zone i call it the zone
yeah i get that i don't like uh arizona
because of the heat it's like
it's too much like i'm just like i
couldn't deal with that on the like
that much that level of heat
uh like for that portion of the larger
portion of the year it's
way too much people born into arizona
they're just used to it yeah uh i don't
know
i i don't know what it is arizona
transplants they got to know what
they're signing up for they got to be
they have to brace for it right we can't
just be a person that doesn't like heat
and decide to move to arizona unless
you cannot control it because that's no
job has taken you i don't find yourself
in that situation
all condolences i know people that have
moved there though and they're like i
love it i love it i'm like but the heat
yeah it's like that weird [ __ ] where
it's like 114 is fine
it's the same thing with this it's dry
but yeah
i don't i mean i'm not dry but it's the
same thing with like parts of canada
there are cities in canada that i love
like there are cities in arizona i
really enjoy
but there are cities in canada and then
i scope i could picture living here and
then you go what's the winter like and
then they tell you and you're like
dad forget it man i can't do it it's the
opposite in arizona it says over 80
degrees you check on your old people all
your old friends and neighbors and stuff
80. that sounds like a lot all right
fair enough
what uh what would you eat this is the
thing i think about in like a climate
like arizona what would you what would
if you lived there what would you eat
because i feel like i'd always be so
hot i could never eat cold hot food i
always have everything would have to be
cold all the time chilled right
a lot of ice and gazpachos
and chilled i don't even know what i was
gonna say like cocktail shrimp
because that's usually on ice but i
don't know if i want shrimp and heat
like that
either i picture eating a lot of shrimp
cocktail you did too
yeah because it's just served in a uh
like with like a slushie as my drink
and uh there's so many things that like
yeah all
hot food seems seems like a pass when
you're in a place that's 120
ice cream for breakfast uh arizona's
only official state food is the state
fish the apache trout
it's a landlocked state is it isn't it
i'm pretty sure yeah it's landlocked
isn't it why would there
well let's hold on before i start
talking here no it's not okay
no it is mexico is up against it yeah
why would would their thing be a fish
yeah but over there by the real edge by
mexico
uh was it new mexico or is that mexico
can't see
mexico goes up over there now right
underneath
that's considered oh yeah sure because
cabo and saw you right uh like down that
area
yeah yeah northern um i guess every
state is a state fish i mean it looks
like it's just a short
jaunt to the water i just didn't know if
maybe i read it wrong i was thinking it
was saying the mascot was a fish
i think it's just saying that they have
a state fish but every state probably oh
it's the official state food
every state has an official state food
that's that's just open up this can of
worms it says
no i'm asking i'm asking it says let's
do it it says
i'm saying i guess every state has a
state fish and a state bird i don't know
however the state
does have some unofficial state foods in
particular the chimichanga
chimichangas otherwise known as a deep
fried burrito are a state favorite that
reflect the states of mexican
agriculture it makes sense makes sense
makes sense chimichanga name a food
with a more fun name than that name it
uh you know garbanzo beans is always
great
garbanzo is fun there's been a lot of
people out of your pocket i like that
i've heard a lot of bits about garbanzo
have you yeah my friend lizzie cooperman
has a very funny bit about the name
what's the bit
i don't remember what are you doing to
me here i don't want to know
she's just like how who do they what am
i doing here who do they who do they
think they are
oh look at me i'm a garbanzo bean
something like that it's very funny
i can't do it but it's funny okay yeah
hopefully you're not getting it right
because i don't see it
don't that's a friend of mine don't say
that i have nothing but nice things i
don't even know her i'm not saying that
but i'm saying your
your take on what she said it feels like
you've got to see her do it that's why i
said what do they do
they gotta see her do her thing right
she's very funny
i don't i still don't think that beats
chimichanga though but garbanzo is great
garbanzo
good sound off in the comments
chimichanga with uh
foods that you think sound fun to say uh
yeah what other what other fun foods are
there hey to the listeners that don't
watch this
hi we never speak to you directly
but if you if you don't have the time or
the energy or
feel the need to watch on video because
our listenership our pure
audio listenership is growing in great
strides
and uh hey pimp i have a question for
you spotify numbers they get reported
back to our
to our ad people or no yeah yeah they're
all added up together spotify is
included in that
because i saw a conversation online this
week uh comics being like
we never signed off on our albums being
on spotify and we don't get paid for it
so how are they who's giving them our
albums that has to deal with who
recorded their album actually owns the
rights
for sure but for us these these spotify
numbers are getting reported back well
then god bless everybody these spotify
numbers count
yeah so if you're just listening you
missed some
great editing uh from the the great
homeless pimp
yes uh there's all these little easter
eggs and zingers in there and he zooms
in and he
he really accentuates our little test
that we have
um but nonetheless we need
audio listenership too and you guys that
are listening audio on your commute and
what have you
this shout out is for you look at that
go back to the state foods in new york
pimp
state fruit the apple that makes sense
state muffin the apple muffin i don't
even know there wasn't lazy but it makes
sense
state snack yogurt steak vegetable
oh no that's now we're into north
carolina huh
this the new york's new york state snack
is yogurt
what a show is there a new york state
fish
no only arizona official fish of new
york is a
oh it's just a trap huh trouts
al trout wig new york state foods
now these are identified with new york
but not a fish
restaurant oh gosh it's pizza de park
that's so funny
uh the classic old-fashioned is a time
oh that's an old fat oh that's new
york's what new york drink is
that's the drink new york is famous for
it's the classic old-fashioned this is
the equivalent of an on-ass stroke we're
having yeah
we just
when it scrolls i can't see what's going
on all right the classic old-fashioned
is a time-tested archetype cocktail
revered by many and hated by few
we actually put that up against the
field with a long catalog of flavor
twists and adaptations including many
pioneered in new york city it's no
surprise
that it makes the classic new york drink
list all right well
that's something today what we're doing
though yeah go to new york
state official dessert google that and
let's see if it falls into
today is a zinger yeah let's see if the
official dessert
it's got to be cheesecake right new york
state
no that doesn't have one new mexico
steak cookie though is
california's official dessert is it a
fortune cookie what is that
biscotti how do you say that that's
pisco
bisco cheeto that's hard to say um
that's a fun word food word business
cheeto is nice i don't even heard that
before
it's like a biscuit and a cheeto
together pimp what's a biscott cheeto
yeah copy it from his name was bisco
piscochito oh look at that it's like a
little oh no i know what a biscochito is
did i say that i tried to put a little
english on it basically means biscuit
and while they are extremely similar to
spanish
mantichatos another fun word shortbreads
shortbreads made with pig fat the
distinctly spicy
disarmingly simple that sounds good
cookies an original new mexican recipe
integral have you had a biscot cheeto
cuisine
sound off in the comments all right
well the reason we asked about sweets is
because of our lineup for today
we we moved uh we we asked better treat
and we change it to which is better
because i took issue with the fact to
have
treat in the poll survey because i think
that would give an unfair advantage
to the rice krispie treat and i'd hear a
hundred times over
it's got treat right in the name oh come
on and i didn't i wanted to eliminate
that
right so sal we got if you can't tell is
foolishly picked
s'mores to go against foolishly
to go against the mighty mighty rice
krispie treat
rice krispie treat is a dime a dozen
watch yourself
watch it's time it doesn't watch
yourself okay it's a cereal with melted
marshmallow on it
full stop okay people make it homemade
or kellogg's make it and they package it
and they put it on shelves and stores
most of them taste pretty similar it's a
nice taste some would say it's acquired
but it's fine it is mixing a breakfast
cereal
one of the greatest breakfasts and a
sweet one of the all-time
greatest breakfast cereals i can
appreciate a rice krispy treat
i couldn't have it every day i got to be
in the mood and when it hits it hits
well
but a s'mores is a decadent
masterpiece that when done right
we'll bring you to another level elaine
elaine
elaine a s'mores is in a lane that a
rice crispy tree i'll tell you where
you're
i'll tell you where your argument has
already gone wrong the words
when done right it's never been done
right
it's impossible s'mores is
it's an impossible thing to concoct at a
campfire i've sat with you and tried to
concoct it at a campfire as you're
supposed to
it is so hard to get it right the
chocolate doesn't melt enough the
marshmallow melts too much you bite it
once it falls completely to pieces
you know as well as i do a s'more is a
damn near impossible thing to get rid of
can i can i say something on the heels
of that though i think that
whole entire experience is part
of what i like about the s'mores okay
it's not just for campfires but while
we're at it if we're there i mean if
you're at a campfire
if you're at a campfire and you have the
ingredients for s'mores
rice krispie treats you might as well
just throw them into the ocean
i mean don't put me in a campfire
setting you're going to want to catch
this morning
for the fifth time three quarters of
your s'more falls into the flames and
you yell
sucker again you're gonna go can i just
have one of these white
graham crackers you got a bag of
marshmallows if you can't fiddle around
and get it to work once you you waste a
couple of marshmallows in the process
so what hot mushrooms i love a
marshmallow that goes a blaze on its own
then you blow it out
and it gets that real charred
caramelized out
it's fun in theory but you can't eat it
till it cools off again and then it just
tastes like burnt cold marshmallow
i i don't think a marshmallow i think a
marshmallow is the most overrated treat
of all time now granted it's in both of
these treats
but i will take a caramelized hot
semi-melted marshmallow i mean
look every day twice on sundays over
the coagulated hardened marshmallows
right now i'll put you to sleep right
now
wow okay i'll put you to sleep right now
make a coco crispies uh rice krispie
treat and you're getting this
you get every great part of the s'mores
with something better than graham
cracker
which is rice krispies here we go you
know that's not here we go
we've been talking about for three
minutes he's abandoned the original rice
krispies i'm not abandoning the cocoa
rice krispie treat already
because he needs help right away it
might be obvious but s'mores are
definitely an american treat and aren't
necessarily known or enjoyed around the
world
per wikipedia the first recorded recipe
for the gooey summer snacks was found in
1927
girl scout publication another brand of
[ __ ] sweets
uh although you're in the minority there
baby no i'm not i [ __ ] all over them
before we talked about the girls got
cookies girl scout cookies suck girl
scout cookies
are um they suck uh they suck we already
know about this girl scout cookies raise
young girls
we already know about this i screamed at
your dumb face about this a long time
ago
they suck they they they any cookie
recipes
they teach a girl cookie recipe that
leans on coconut
i mean your controversy and business and
supply and demand
and baking and annoying their neighbors
and knocking on doors unsolicited
courtesy calls intrusive behaviors are
the worst industries in america
uh i had a box of girl scout cookies
right here right now you oh thumb your
nose at it yep
no you wouldn't i would thumb my nose at
it no you wouldn't i would thumb my nose
out no you wouldn't you need to look in
my eyes and see how serious i am
i would not touch them i wouldn't even
be every single flavor
yes i don't believe you yes you're not
being reasonable
i'm i'm being reasonable they've said if
i had their product lined in front of me
not worth the council
boxes not you wouldn't buy one the cow
you know how full of [ __ ] you are
every episode we do from now until the
end of this season i'm gonna have
all 10 boxes of girl scout cookies in
front of us
and i want to see you resist them go
ahead i will every single tell you what
put a bag of combos on top of each box
i'll resist all of it i don't give a
[ __ ] you should just give in
you should give in to what you know is
true in your heart
which is that the combo is a wonderful
snack that's been around for a long time
without any help from advertisement
because it doesn't need it
and that it's underrated and you know
what everyone loves an underdog story
and i think that i will take underrated
treats
over most popular treats all the time i
like something that flies a little under
the radar
that being said it's just more literally
the opposite of every argument you ever
makes
every argument you ever make is it's a
powerhouse it's been around since the
beginning of time
it's undeniable it's everybody's
favorite this that's awesome
i didn't say i didn't like powerhouses i
just said a lot of times i like the
underdog
in instead of a powerhouse because it's
not the regular thing that everyone
always goes for
you could go to a campsite and and and
and have a better shot handing out rice
crispy treats
than you would with this is why this is
why some of our listeners
actually hate you right with a passion
because the sentence like you can go to
a campfire and people will tell you
what's right
christmas treats over cause i'll tell
you why s'mores and i'll tell you why
are literally because i connected why
but i'll tell you why
i'll tell you why because once you get
past the excitement
and this is what happened to me the
first time i made s'mores when i was a
kid i was so excited to make these
things
once you get past the excitement of
putting it together
and realizing it is a gigantic pain in
the ass without a microwave oven
hold on you get tired of it and you get
bored
and what you start doing is eating the
ingredients separately
and plain chocolate with plain graham
crackers
and plain marshmallows is boring let me
finish is boring
and on top of it why i make the claim
and for all of you doubters out there
i bet you agree with me after i say this
you can't get a kid
to put his cell phone down now you think
you're going to go to a campsite
and get a kid excited to put a s'more
together because
what a ridiculous argument because kids
you dangle you
in front of them to get them to even go
on the camping trips you're not getting
a
child that is sitting in a campfire that
will rip your
eyeballs out to not get a skewer and the
ingredients for a s'mores kids will flip
their lids to make a s'mores over an
open flame at a campfire
all everybody want to do is put them on
they're crunching
they want to see the chocolate melts
they want to put it into a sandwich
a kid don't care that it's all over the
face closing hands
bitcoin numbers on their phones do you
think they're going to be wood with a
stick and a cracker
yeah i do because no nine year old is
getting bitcoin stop put the hyperbole
there's a national s'mores day it's
celebrated august 10th
look at that only in this country yeah
you have a lot of trouble with the rest
of the world
in other countries hopefully they've
heard of s'mores before which by this
way
looks stylized and it means there's some
more i said i want some more as if it's
that good look at this look at this
dumbass claim
when making a s'more try something extra
by adding a slice of banana
strawberry a peanut butter cup a
maraschino chip
yeah make it even harder to keep the
thing together actually that is
wonderful i can't wait to try those
things a peanut butter cup or a banana
i really would love to try that i'm
gonna show you in theory
making a making a smart an open fire
it's literally like saying let's make
club sandwiches on the [ __ ]
you have a foot club together or the
[ __ ]
you look down right here you look down
right here i got two plates okay
one has a s'more on it okay it's a
golden toasted caramelized marshmallow
i've never seen
it in my life it's a beautiful milk
chocolate that is kind of almost melted
in between the sandwich of two delicious
golden graham
crackers you have that a piping hot
fresh readily made source and by the way
if you get at a restaurant or you get it
in the form of a pop tart whatever the
combination is
chocolate and graham cracker is way way
more tasty delectable and
and desirable than rice crispies rice
crispy rice oh and marshmallows you stop
shorter too maybe you throw butter in it
but it's
would you want that or you want a bowl
you know they let me finish now
do you want a brick of crisp
rice yes they do with dry meat
stickiness over there yes i do
over yes freshly made here we go
chocolate combination marshmallow s'more
joe you're ridiculous joe
so say that those two convenient even
competitions but here's
i'm in a lane i'm in my rear view mirror
looking at looking at the right
retreat i'm looking at you in the
rearview mirror you you're just on
ingredients alone you get rocked
i got chocolate i got chocolate involved
yeah chocolate the flavor you went
against lost the vanilla
i have marshmallow no no it didn't yes
it did vanilla one
that's what i'm saying it lost to
vanilla chocolate and i had vanilla
i know i'm saying stop touting about
this flavor that you say is so great
when it when it got creamed against the
vanilla we were talking ice cream
no we were talking flavors shut up we
were talking about ice cream
i love butcher box i love butcher blocks
but it's not in the copy i say that of
my own merit
so do i i love a range of pork and
beef and meat delivered to my home that
are high quality cuts
that i don't have to go out for and lug
home they come frozen
i throw right in the freezer and then i
am good for the month i
especially love it because it's
summertime i love to cook
particularly love cooking meat
particularly love cooking meat in the
summertime bbq babies particularly
love cooking meat in the summertime on
the grill butcher box is hooking me up
options like a hundred percent grass-fed
and finished beef nobody likes
incomplete beef let's
free-range organic chicken nothing's
better than free
humanely raised pork wild caught lobster
tails wild card alaskan salmon
and sugar nitrate free free bacon that's
the thing about it all
it's it's it's all humane uh each box
ships with nine to 11 pounds of meat
pack fresh ship frozen vacuum sealed
it's simple to store in the freezer like
i said
you throw it in there you grab it later
on the go i love it the way it's
packaged it lasts forever
it's so convenient it's so affordable
it's
just everything you need right now to
make your summer and just day-to-day
life
even that much better so i feel lucky
that butcherbox is sponsoring us
and that they want you to celebrate this
summer
they want to help you out so new members
you're getting two free lobster tails
and two free ribeyes in your first box
so you can
do a high quality surf and turf with
your friends right off the bat
this is what you can do sign up choose
your box and your delivery frequency
they offer
four curated box options and a custom
box that lets you choose what you want
uh butcherbox ships you the order frozen
peak freshness and packed in an
eco-friendly
100 recyclable box you enjoy high
quality meat delivered to your door
and more time for amazing meals together
i'm loving all of this stuff
all this stuff now where we don't have
to go out anymore and and just lug
around and actually go to the
supermarket
and it gets i mean i'm looking for
convenience
my time is money i'm looking to save
time uh butcher box is offering our
listeners of taste buds
two five ounce lobster tails and two
10-ounce ribeyes for free in your first
box
you only get this special deal when you
sign up for a new membership it's
butcherbox.com
taste buds that's butcherbox
dot com slash taste buds free lobster
tails and rib eyes in your first box
come on
put your box surf and turf on them
it's wild so you're doing a lot of
shopping online
always me too babe i know the women be
shopping but you know who also be
shopping
men joe and joe
the taste buds be shopping look folks
it's this simple
honey is a service that's going to give
you access
a service okay that's going to get would
you think i said you said it weird
okay it's a service that's going to give
you instant access to millions of promo
codes
when you are checking out on many of
your favorite websites honey will
automatically fill in the promo code box
for you
at the checkout it's a plugin that adds
to your browser
it won't fill with just one promo code
either it'll dump
a ton of promo codes into your checkout
you can test them in seconds and see
if one gives you a discount look he's
got it right here this is this is
different than every other thing we talk
about because
we're usually telling you to order
something
this is like it's going to help you save
on things there's nothing to order
the discounts i've said it's it's been
great i love honey
i love because i was a guy that would
google discount code at checkout for
such and such
uh i love honey it's like getting a
million promo codes from this one
little podcast talk about all the time
every time i online shop i get to the
checkout page
and it says promo code and then i'm like
oh my god they exist and then i go on a
hunt
for promo codes uh i leave the page and
then
95 of the time they just don't work this
takes all that out also they're gonna
give you five bucks
you can just get five bucks in your
venmo account just for trying out honey
all you have to do to get those five
bucks is go to joinhoney.com
taste buds and sign up with the email
associated
with your venmo account by june 30th
okay so five bucks into your venmo
account plus
all those free promo codes by going to
joinhoney.com
taste buds that's join honey.com taste
buds do it by june 30th
oh my god listen to me listen to me i'm
going to say something right now
i don't give a [ __ ] you got marshmallow
and you got crisp rice that's what you
got and that's all you need baby
chocolate and graham crackers that's all
you need
are you nuts your favorite cereal you
almost took golden grahams against
fruit loops because you love graham
crackers so much golden grahams don't
taste like graham crackers golden crabs
take a variation of graham crackers that
are infinitely more delicious thank you
very much
that's like saying cinnamon toast crunch
tastes like french toast oh you're
falling apart at the seams
yes you are trying to make a point don't
taste like crab crackers
i said they taste like elevated graham
crackers they don't taste like a graham
cracker out of the box
you think you think your low rent
bag of graham cracker substitute
is better than the original thing you
think a cereal is better than the
actual graham cracker yes americans buy
90 million
pounds of marshmallows every year
additionally during the summer it's
estimated
50 of marshmallows sold are used for
s'mores
so weird that they don't make them in a
store packaged as a common snack that
you see against every famous
candy bar in the entire world let me
tell you something right now so weird no
no
i want to make my point against no you
just yelled for five minutes i'm going
to make it i'm sorry i was doing an
impression of you i'm just going to make
a point
look who's talking look what you're
talking to all right
i'm gonna make a point so this is here
you go again
with the elusive bigfoot argument that's
not gonna start calling it with you
a toasted golden brown hold on a toasted
golden brown s'more
with the chocolate just right and the
marshmallow i have never
seen it sound because you're don't never
look you're not
you don't you own a sandwich shop but
you can't hold a marshmallow over a
flame
i made these as a kid with my folks and
i said i don't want to do this anymore
it
sucks it's impossible to make it right
oh dude just joe just give up on
everything then
you can't battle through us mores
you can't at the end of s'mores you're
just unraveled it's
not a sound way to make a stand let me
tell you something right now
that's ridiculous nothing against the
breakfast scene look at that look at
that
beautiful that looks that looks
beautiful that looks like
like that looks like something weird it
looks like delicious marshmallows
by the way i got new smoothies with
semen i got news for you buddy boy
a lot of people throw chocolate chips
into the rice krispie treats
so you can have chocolate in there too
well let's talk about the classic
recipes please okay
you cheap okay let's talk about adding a
maraschino cherry to the s'more i just
said i would like to try that i didn't
put it up against the rice sushi can i
say something right now
standalone i already told you
marshmallow for me is an overrated treat
granted it's in both it's a wash
but your two ingredients are crispy rice
rice krispies alone look at the
ingredients oh rice krispies alone
it's butter it's rice krispies alone
butter is huge
butter but listen to me is rice krispie
alone a delectable desire
top-notch actual dessert treat no
is marshmallow alone can you look at me
when i speak to you
i don't want can you not look past me
and almost i it almost
almost sounds like your ears are also
closed your face tells me that your ears
are also shut
please your two ingredients your two big
bangers
marshmallow take it or leave it whatever
i think a marshmallow terrible argument
you're making this is like
you thought your ingredient is you price
but salt you fought for peanut butter
and jelly and your whole argument was
these two flavors are so good together
it's all you need
it's sometimes all you need is two
flavors you don't need more than that
my point to you is this plain old
chocolate a plain old marshmallow and a
plain old graham cracker
all suck by themselves they're all
awesome and they combined to make a
goddamn
voltron so you wouldn't go rice
christmas
three elves you would sit on the couch
like snap crackle pop
you would simply couch you would sit on
a couch and eat a box of plain graham
crackers oh you don't even know
that's crazy graham cracker a golden
graham cracker it's delicious you dunk
that [ __ ] milk i'll go through a sleeve
grab that's crazy golden grahams is your
favorite cereal it tastes like a better
graham cracker
if it tastes just like a graham cracker
wouldn't it taste like a graham cracker
better or not okay coco chocolate
i prefer to regular chocolate they both
they both have marshmallow the
marshmallows are
washed now i'm left with chocolate and
graham crackers and you're left
with crispy rice and what you're left
with what you're left with
is undercooked chocolate yeah a burnt
marshmallow and a raw graham cracker
you have to go to the desert fantasy
version in the picture does not exist
okay this never happened okay you ever
go to a deli and you see them they try
to pull off
the homemade rice krispies bricks to you
that they rather their own saran wrap
the ones that sell out every day
the ones that sell out the amazing ones
that are huge that i would buy
almost every single day it looks like
you're eating literally like you're
like you're a brick mason yeah funny
i've never seen
never seen s'mores because s'mores jokes
because s'mores are made over in open
flames
[ __ ] flames aren't in dela contestants
where are we at with votes pimpy 10 875
votes where are we at with time
you love going to the phones when you
when i got you on the road
when i got me on the road because i'm
trying to keep this on the phone because
i'm trying to keep us on track
we're on track it's only 25 minutes i
asked where we were at on time that's
all i asked
i'm not allowed to ask where we're at on
time i like to go to the polls
i didn't go to the polls pimp went to
the polls did you see me click the polls
i said where are we at on time you said
what did the polls say
no i didn't i said where we out on votes
and where are we at on time i just want
to see how many people vote where we out
on votes is not what do the polls say
i wanted to see how many people voted
the number of votes so far
because you're antsy you're antsy to get
out of the conversation because you're
on the ropes
all right rice krispie treats
offer children they're for children even
malamar
rice krispy treat is someone else's
first grade a s'mores
is for anybody anybody even
above 18. even malamar's about can only
be bought
even malamar's could only be bought for
certain months out of the year
because of the conditions they have to
be shipped in it's
that does not even apply to this
argument how does it not apply
because because the rules for it to be
shipped
are you are gonna are gonna come into
play when we're talking the taste
between the two also it's in malamar
it's got the ingredient
there you go they've perfected s'mores
not needing to be made over an open
flame you still have all three
ingredients and people live and die
by malinois my dad's favorite cookie
why am i not seeing these three flavors
put together everywhere else why am i
always
what do you mean what's in the world
campgrounds have them too
pinwheels they're the same version why
am i only seeing these three flavors
together
once a year [ __ ] by the way weddings
for weddings it's a special treat at
weddings [ __ ] artists
you're so full of [ __ ] you had them at
weddings
i could tell you three weddings i had
out the top of my head okay i went to
the white face lodge upstate to my
friend keith and liz's wedding they had
a big open flame
and s'mores were the hit of the wedding
and the buddhist band played at it oh
that's so weird a bunch of people in
their 40s and 50s and 60s loved s'mores
50s and 60s i went to this wedding 10
years ago when i was in my 30s
i'm telling you well i don't understand
your arguments it doesn't matter as a
kid i was molested by a stranger offered
me some s'mores i'll go with rice
krispie treats
if you're into being molested all means
go with sports
well look look honestly which is her
name
it says honestly i don't um i'm sorry
that you got molested
but also you're insane at you know
independent of the molestation you're
insane if you think that
people that makes more are going to let
you every time that's ridiculous
this is one of the hottest i've ever
seen you on the show i don't know why
you're so worked up about it because i
because you're getting into territory
where your arguments just they just
don't make any sense
it makes perfect sense sal tell me what
i said that doesn't make sense
everything you said is holy no that's
not true that's not true
and that's a cop-out tell me what i said
that doesn't make sense it's [ __ ]
it's just ridiculous no
tell me what it's just ridiculous tell
me what i think that a rice crispy treat
no
tell me what i said tell me what i
said that doesn't make sense you have
yet to counter argue that they're very
hard to make you have yet to
counter argue they're a little messy
they're fun
you say they're horrible little messy
they're fun you were complaining
about the margarita coming off the glass
right i see that's part of it
it's fun to try to perfect it make a
good one the next bit
you never know where you're getting with
the s'mores sometimes it strokes a
little too much sometimes it's not we
were
just a little given a choice we were
just guys marshmallow light ablaze and
they're really charred sometimes they're
not
it's all in how you work it that's a fun
problem
look you could tell me look that's like
arguing that you love
jelly beans because you think finding
them on the easter egg hunt and that
process is part of the experience
it's got nothing to do with the final
product and the flavor of the food
and you know as well as i do when we
were down the shore
when we were down the shore a year ago
we got some more
we did and it lasted pimp i would say
12 minutes there was about 12 minutes of
honest
how long was supposed to last nobody
could
that's not true i'll call everybody up
who was on that trip with us we all ate
s'mores
so this is joe this is joe's this is you
know this the way the way joe takes
information and then
puts it back out is so wildly inaccurate
we bought s'mores we sat around a
literal fire pit
and we all ate s'mores and we all liked
it
first of all one year we all hated the
s'mores
no one else i didn't say we all hated it
12 minutes it's just not true
we all hated it i said it lasted 12
minutes because nobody could do it and
you're tired of it
you give up when are you home you're
home in your kitchen just throwing
around krispies
you throw it on krispies and
marshmallows i like my crispies babe i
don't got to make them
okay i buy them because they put my
flavors together out in the wild for
sale
they don't put but you want everybody
you want to tell you want to tell me
that
what do you mean malamars you want to
tell me right now that
that it's annoying because you don't you
always fumble and don't know how to make
a smile
but meanwhile homemade rice krispie
treat you don't even dabble
you're just arguing for the pre-packaged
rice krispies i don't bake
i don't bake it's not baking it's not
baking
it's not baking there's no heat involved
there's not an oven involved you dope
conserve energy well they must overheard
us
conserve energy new york is urging this
must be fun for our listeners
pimp's just going off now whoa wait a
minute new york city is urging all
households and businesses to
immediately limit energy usage to
prevent power outages
as the intense heat continues please
avoid the use of energy-intensive
appliances
such as washers dryers and microwaves
limit unnecessary use of air
conditioning well i have the air
blasting full
all right let's keep moving before the
lights go out a smores
this comes from jenna a s'more is a
delicacy a celebration a rice krispie
treat
is what you bring to school as a snack
how many people got that conditioner
i mean do you have do you see that i'm
reading sorry
do you like a taste of your own medicine
are you nuts you ignored me
i'm reading a comment that supports you
from one of the fans and you start
talking over it because you decided to
exit the conversation
we all have it about new york city said
this is a good comment
what is the matter with you i'm sorry
joe i just got an alert from the
government
i hope sorry if i wanted to i hope you
used to talk about conserving energy
i hope you lose i hope you lose so bad
today
i hope you lose rice krispies goes out
of business and you can never
have another one in your life and by the
way by the way a friend of ours does
bake
and that friend of ours is not bad let
me finish
let me finish you just melted you just
melted that friend of ours
baked for us on that trip and i
guarantee you if that friend had baked
delicious rice krispie treats
while he sat on the couch you would have
loved every second of it i'm comparing
rice krispies
to a s'mores i'm not saying that i would
i would never eat a rice krispie treat
that's what i'm doing
and there's no baking involved joe you
just melt the butter and you melt the
marshmallow you roll it around the rice
krispies and you let it sit
it hardens and you eat it did i just
blow your mind
that you thought what did you think
people were throwing the [ __ ] in the
oven you throw it in the oven
i don't believe that you do you know
recipe please large saucepan melts
butter on low heat you're not baking
anything
and kellogg's rice krispie treats stir
that's it coat with cooking [ __ ]
i thought you had to bake them i don't
know they're delicious but how much do
you love rice krispie treats if you've
never
even made them and didn't even know how
what do i got to make them
but you've made s'mores to the store as
i said to you 800 times i'm saying i
made them one time and it
sucked if you left every time i tried to
return to this oh was it hard to make
them
it's impossible oh so so that was your
gripe against the s'mores so you have
the equal gripe again
to treat your defenders no no i'm no i'm
talking about s'mores weren't possible
why not but if you love rice krispie
treats so much why don't you try to walk
to the store and buy them but it's just
but why why would i when i could just
buy them because why would you not want
to try your own home why would you
why would you do that with any food do
you cook at home at all why cook all the
time
why i cook things that i find why do you
make spaghetti and meatballs when you
can order it from the delicious
pizza in my meatballs whatever joe
whatever
my meatballs are better than any
meatballs i'm gonna buy anywhere so i'm
gonna make my own meatballs why do you
make stuff at home as opposed to
ordering everything at the store
sometimes you save money
sometimes because i make it better okay
so you love rice krispie treats yet
in your whole time on this earth you've
never been like
let me try to make my own it's simple i
love it no because i thought it was
baking quite frankly
and i don't think you don't even know i
don't bake what goes into a rice krispie
treat
i walk to the store and i buy it you
showed your hand you showed your hands
like a king
you showed your hand you don't even see
you don't even know you don't even know
let's read a few more quotes you don't
even know what the rice krishi was
comprised of i had to tell you it was
butter
let's let's let's let's you defend
defending a treat that you have
low to little knowledge of s'mores are
the trailer park
cousin messy and never altogether rice
krispie treats are the high class
options that is the stupidest thing i
actually want to i actually want to
consult
i actually want to insult whoever this
is who who did that
easy baby hizzy baby
that is so far anybody who knows
anything about life or writing a joke
would know
that the rice krispie treat is the low
can you scroll back to that pimp s'mores
are the trailer part
everyone knows the rice crispy never all
together rice krispie treats would be
assigned the trailer park option there
and the high questions because mice
crispy treats are never messy and not
all together s'mores always are
that's my point you want to tell me this
elusive bigfoot uh s'more that doesn't
exist that nobody's ever seen then fine
i want i want to buy i want to spend
money
although i work for hershey's i gotta
give it to rice crispy
i want to spend money on cereal that has
had melted marshmallow dumped on it
wrapped in saran wrap or shits like a
brick on top of a deli counter
i want to take it at lukewarm
temperature open it up not pre-packaged
from the factory mind you
open up someone's weird saran wrap and i
want to just bite and you know what you
ever get
half the time yourself in a situation
on a stick that a raccoon [ __ ] pissed
off
and you're worried about a deli saran
wrap half the time i've eaten a rice
krispie treat it's been stale
disgust oh please discuss it not once
you not once not once you've never had a
stale rice christmas tree
oh you must live in the village with the
elves whatever i mean
i'll tell you what folks i like a drink
i do like a drink no kidding
and i'll tell you the thing i have a
hard time with sometimes that there are
a lot of different varieties of drink
out there that i care
for and there are a lot of specific
types of drink
and varieties within those specific
types of drink that i like
for instance maybe i'm driving at a hard
seltzer here
you got a lot of hard seltzers out on
that market what but does any
distinguish themselves from anyone else
and for good reason this is what i like
about vizzy
vizzy is the only first and only heart
seltzer
with antioxidant vitamin c they're
bringing something unique and delicious
to the table
jesus how long have you waited for a
booze that's also
good for you i do i i do want to feel a
little better about drinking
hard salsas are delicious you can pound
them down but even better if i'm getting
antioxidants and vitamin c in there
you're kidding me
there are plenty of heart cells to
choose from but with eight bold and
delicious
dual fruit flavors and antioxidants
vitamin c visit makes the choice
a little easier it's a lot tastier i
love these flavors too pineapple mango
black cherry lime strawberry kiwi
blueberry pomegranate my favorite papaya
passion fruit watermelon strawberry
blackberry lemon also delish raspberry
tangerine come on guys
come on guys get with vizzy you can now
enjoy refreshment with antioxidant
vitamin c
come on guys come on guys get with vizzy
you can enjoy a refreshment that also
has
antioxidant vitamin c five percent
alcohol by volume 100 calories
and less than one gram of real cane
sugar
per can every sip of izzy is more
exhilarating
go over to vizzy hardseltzer.com
tastebuds that's v-i-z-z-y-hard
seltzer dot com slash taste buds go to
vizi
hard seltzer dot com slash taste buds
check it out for yourself upgrade your
hard seltzer to fizzy
sal i want to talk to you about buffy
and their latest product
the breeze comforter i know all about it
it's hypoallergenic
100 it's breathable fiber eucalyptus
it's good on the planet it's sustainable
it regulates your temperature you will
not overheat you will not have night
sweats it's softer than
cotton eucalyptus uses 10 times less
water than cotton to grow
and its fiber is produced using
recyclable earth friendly solvents look
we got a lot of globally conscious
you know earth friendly listeners
yeah and for them we have a special
product just for them
just for them we can head up all the
time we love them if you're not earth
conscious too it's still a great product
yeah exactly you know but you could just
be you could be your regular old piece
of garbage and still
enjoy this don't enjoy that you could
you could be throwing plastic bottles in
the street and still let it be puffy the
point is is buffy's doing the right
thing
uh and i love this comforter i had
actually purchased a new
comforter right before i got my buffy
one and i put the old
the new one under my bed and i only use
the buffy one now
because it finally took away my night
sweats it finally kept me cool and
comfortable all night long and i do
like quite a bit that it's cruelty free
it's not hurting any animals it's
hypoallergenic and all that other good
stuff
even if all that stuff doesn't tickle
your fancy the point is is that it's
soft and breathable okay and this is the
best part
and i like any company that does this
it's a free trial and if you don't like
it you can return it at no cost which
means it's completely risk-free
so you hear us talk about this stuff all
the time products here products there
and maybe you don't want to take the
plunge for something like this they take
that guesswork out of it order it you
don't like it send it back they give you
your money back
exactly what do you have to do go to
buffy.co that's buffy.co and enter the
code tastebuds
that's b-u-f-f-y dot c-o and enter the
code taste buds you're gonna get 20
off your buffy comforter plus that free
trial thanks buffy
whenever i make a s'more and the
marshmallow isn't perfectly golden brown
i hear gordon ramsay my head saying you
cook the [ __ ] out of it it's [ __ ] raw
it's way too hard to get it right
well i'm seeing a trend here in the
comments that sound a lot like what i've
been saying the whole time
right what we're discussing is how to
get it right
not just the taste inadmissible nobody's
ever had the taste because nobody's ever
had it made right
joe do you want to do you want to just
let me
let you want to let before you speak
again before you speak again do you want
me to let that comment you just shout it
out
as you said that comment i saw your eyes
and you knew
that you said one of the classic joe
derosa comments that is
not true everybody nobody's ever made it
look what everybody
is true look at what everybody is saying
everybody is saying if i lose if i lose
if i lose you're going to yeah because
you know what you got the brand name
behind you because these people
no right crispy no kellogs excuses
excuses
i don't i don't know maybe i'm just i
think i said you wanted to do this this
was yours
a more decadent treat it's i think it's
a more creative treat
i think it's a more fun experience to
eat i think that when you have
s'mores you're actually you're you
everyone's excited oh let's have s'mores
tonight oh
we'll get the ingredients s'mores
you're making two different arguments
food fresh in the palm of your hand is
one argument i will listen to that
argument
ambiance for quality of food is not an
argument
it's like saying i like crawfish better
than shrimp because i enjoy
the ambiance and experience of pulling
the tails off and sucking on
you stupid [ __ ] it's ridiculous
bringing this up on the heels of you
saying that you hate it because you
could never make it right and it's too
difficult to make so you could put a
strawberry
you could put it let me try you can put
a strike against the s'mores for how
hard it is to make and i can't counter
argue
your point and say i think making it is
fun and then you tell me
you can't bring in this it is the white
what are you talking
about the white whale moby dicks of
foods it doesn't exist
it's not real it has never occurred i
have never seen it because
of the movie moby dicks of dicks
s'mores the gangbang of flavors well
rice krispies is just cereal
marshmallows that's one that agrees with
you
there you go i could already hear oh
here we go
i could already hear whoever arguing for
rice crispy saying s'mores are too messy
guess what though it's worth it oh there
you go s'mores give a great summer vibe
and they're fun to make
easy choice for me who the [ __ ]
oh yeah who the [ __ ] would choose that
dry ass sponge looking disgrace of a
snack over us more that's very funny
this s'more is too much work for too
little of reward
you have to craft a whole ass fire roast
the marshmallow put it together
then after the first bite you've got a
sticky marshmallow melted chocolate ham
as well as graham crackle crumbs
in your lap rice crispy s'mores are
super messy
you know i don't hear i don't hear
anyone being like but but but that guy
will complain about the whole point of
making a s'more
but that's too little reward but then
but
rice krispie treats come together and
the flavor is consistent and it's a
consistent experience
s'mores you might get one bite of the
mixture
and then it falls apart and you're
eating three separate ingredients again
no you're not yes you are nobody starts
just pounding all the ingredients
separately
but you in this fake hypothetical
argument everybody
just goes forward and it's sticky and
you get sticky
and that's your partner number one
complaining is the messiness of food in
this podcast you've argued that more
than anything else i've heard you
arguing again not true
i don't know what pimp pimp pimp
pimp pimp pimp when you hear my voice
when you hear my voice in this podcast
do you hear me constantly complaining
about how messy a food is
you did it on the last episode you
complained about the messiness of the
margarita on the last episode all i did
was say that
that the salt always ends up in the
messy drink
falling you did it with the ice cream
sandwich you said it sucked having the
chocolate all over your fingers
i said a big deal you lick it off your
fingers you said that's disgusting i
don't want to do that
right now you're saying power through
the s'more it's great licking the whoops
off here because this is part of the
whole experience of a s'mores i think
that this
is an endearing quality to the s'mores
i'm not allowed to have
nuance in my opinions you you're gonna
tell me that it's a blanket oh jeffy see
when i start talking do you see what he
does
you see what he checks out he looks
forward and he blocks me out completely
when i'm actually making a calm
counterpoint he'll say his point and
then he'll ignore my counterpart we're
both guilty of that
we're both guilty of that we both talk
over each other we both don't listen
i'm sorry finish your point i don't want
to finish your point
finish your point
stop it i'm done with this episode uh
all right sal is going to use the
messiness argument against whichever one
he isn't defending and he's right
that guy's way off uh if i had a dollar
for every pan of rice krispies treats
i've
eat i've changed shame eating in my life
i'd almost have enough for the rising
cost of insulin in this country
uh what do you think potential winner
no no
you are hot dude it's i'm actually
sweating because it is so hot out today
damn that's a good one
all your others had relatively obvious
answers whoa
well we got to pick a winner buddy i
swear to god if i lose
even if i lose if this is not my neck
[Music]
it's not funny it's not funny it's funny
that we would retweet it yeah retweet
that
who knows if she even got molested
what's her name i know she might be
kitty
i hope she didn't i hope she just was
making a joke and if she did get
molested she's comfortable enough
talking about it
we're just following your tone all right
uh
where's she at uh
on oh it is a guy uh don't kill at don't
kill justin follow at
don't kill justin you can't you can't
put up a a deli counter
treat by the register to something
that's made over an open flame with
better ingredients
that's my closing that's okay and my
closing argument is this that's like
saying
a hot dog because you roasted over an
oven flame with a stick
and the experience of all that and the
fact that you're cooking it on a flame
yourself
is better than any deli sandwich you
could get because it's
i just don't agree it is not true it is
not like saying that
why is when you draw comparisons no i
actually drew a great comparison
no you didn't that's a big camping thing
put hot dogs on a stick
put it over the flame won't that be fun
yeah it's fun for five minutes then you
go
this doesn't taste that great i'd rather
have like a [ __ ] cheeseburger from
mcdonald's
nobody's ever going to you know but you
probably enjoy you probably enjoy a
freshly charred open flamed
hot dog you you you you take the
narrative to just
to appeal to your point you always do
that
no one's ever roasted a hot dog and
liked it never no i didn't say that what
i said
you said no i said it's good but it's
like saying
you compared combining three ingredients
that are better together
there some of their parts are greater
than individually and having them hot
and the experience of them melting
are all part of the charm to comparing
putting a hot dog on fire and
choosing a deli sandwich instead okay if
i want to cook a hot dog over an open
flame
bun it all with with peppers on it or
some kind of
third ingredient that i think makes hot
dogs great ketchup
whatever it is if i'm gonna cook a hot
dog all over number four because it's
three ingredients
and it all comes together or the open
flame and it's so clean and then there's
a guy next to me with a grill
and he goes i can just grill you up a
lobster i'd be like
no the experience of making the hot dog
on the open flame
it's just so special to me you believe
that that lobster's only one ingredient
mine is three it's better
my hawk goes out to all the people
listening and watching right now that
are in their car punching the steering
wheels
that are listening to this man make
arguments that make no logical sense
whatsoever
just because of lobster to rice crispy
treats and s'mores all right pimp
show us the numbers baby
it's gotta hurt it's gotta hurt
to lose by that little it's gotta hurt
it's gotta hurt to lose by that little
week i lost by the greatest margin of
victory ever
and this week i'm down to one percent
they both sting just as much this hurts
more
51.6 percent rice chris this is this is
rematch territory it's under two percent
it means that in
an hour and in three hours and in five
hours we could check back and the tides
could easily swing
this is this is actually actual this is
actual [ __ ]
buddy look at me look at me
buddy look at me
look at me
look at me look at me you know what you
don't have to look at me
the gloating the gloating this this
is actually you know what i am what i am
i'm mad at our listeners right now
i'm mad at our listeners right now
because they this one they got wrong
this one they got wrong well guess what
it's it's it's a
box of rice krispies well guess what
with marshmallow guess what
i still love you i love you too
wait keep this going don't forget to
write to us what's it what's the
address info tastebudspod.com for the
merch hit us up with what merch
you'd like to see uh both what you'd
like to see it on
if you'd like us to do some kitchen
stuff or some food stuff not just
t-shirts or hoodies or hats which we'll
probably do
uh you know we might put them on some
glasses who knows you might have some
fun stuff i don't know maybe oven some
sippy cups that'd be fun
maybe a stick water bottles that you'd
bring into the forest
to make a smoothie and let us know and
let us know what you want on
on the merch you know what oh
oh maybe a spatula that you'd maybe mix
up some rice krispie treats with
hit us up they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds